>> DO YOU TAKE ANY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR YOUR POLICY?
>> OUR POLLSIES HELP, NOT HURT.
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT BIDEN TAKING
ZERO RESPONSIBILITY FOR RECORD
HIGH INFLATION AND CLAIMS THAT
HE'S HELPING AMERICANS.
SOMEBODY AT THE WHITE HOUSE
FORGOT TO TELL BIDEN THE FACTS
AND THE POLLS SAY OTHERWISE.
AMERICANS ARE GETTING CRUSHED BY
AN AVALANCHE OF ECONOMIC
DISASTERS.
GAS PRICES HIT ANOTHER RECORD
HIGH.
MORE AMERICANS ARE STRUGGLING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET.
PARENTS CAN'T EVEN FIND BABY
FORMULA.
THE PRESIDENT MAKING IT CLEAR HE
HAS NO PLAN TO FIX ALL OF THE
PROBLEMS AND INSTEAD HE'S
BLAMING THE USUAL SUSPECTS.
>> THERE'S TWO LEADING CAUSES OF
INFLATION WE'RE SEEING TODAY.
THE FIRST CAUSE IS THE ONES IN A
CENTURY PANDEMIC.
THE SECOND CAUSE, MR. PUTIN'S
WAR IN UKRAINE.
YOU SAW -- WE SAW IN MARTHA --
MARCH THAT 60% WAS DUE TO THE
WAR.
>> Jesse: AND THE GOP HAS NOT
SIGNED ON TO ANYTHING.
AND PUSHING A TALKING UPON THAT
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HAS CALLED
A LIE.
>> SENATOR SCOTT LAID IT OUT.
THE ULTRA MAGA PLAN.
IT'S TO RAISE TAXES ON WORKING
FAMILIES.
LOWTER INCOME OF AMERICAN
WORKERS.
I NEVER EXPECTED THE ULTRA MAGA
REPUBLICANS WHO SEEM TO CONTROL
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY NOW TO HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO CONTROL THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO LISTEN TO
WHAT DANA HAS TO SAY ABOUT ULTRA
MAGA.
FIRST, LET'S LISTEN TO WHAT JEN
PSAKI HAD TO SAY ABOUT HOW THIS
PHRASE CAME TO BE.
>> IT'S THE PRESIDENT'S PHRASE
AND THE PRESIDENT MADE THOSE
COMMENTS HIMSELF JUST LAST WEEK
AS YOU KNOW.
I THINK WHAT HAS STRUCK HIM IS
HOW EXTREME SOME OF THE POLICIES
AND PROPOSALS ARE THAT A CERTAIN
WING OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
THAT IS TAKING UP TOO MUCH OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY ARE FOR.
SO TO HIM, ADDING A LITTLE ULTRA
TO IT GAVE IT A LITTLE EXTRA
POP.
>> Jesse: IS HE GIVING IT AN
EXTRA POP?
>> Dana: I CAN'T STAND IT.
I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE WALKING DOWN
THIS AISLE AT THE CONVENIENCE
STORE OR CVS AND LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING THAT WOULD SAY IS
ULTRA MAGA AND IT'S GROSS TO ME.
I CAN'T STAND IT AND CAN'T GET
IT OUT OF MY HEAD AND I WANT
THEM TO STOP.
BECAUSE HE SAYS ULTRA MAGA 20
TIMES IS NOT GOING TO MAKE
INFLATION GO AWAY.
THEY CAN SAY RICK SCOTT 100,000
TIMES.
HE'S EATING ALONE AT THE LUNCH
TIME.
NOBODY IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
THAT SIGNED ON.
BY NO MEANS IS AN ULTRA MAGA
GROUP SUPPORTIVE.
THEY SAY THAT RICK SCOTT WANTS
TO RAISE TAXES.
THAT'S SO EXTREME.
THEY WANT TO RAISE TAXES.
WHY DON'T THEY JUMP ON BOARD?
CHOICE VERSUS A REFERENDUM.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'LL HEAR ME SAY A
HUNDRED TIMES.
AS MANY TIMES AS THEY SAY ULTRA
MAGA, I'LL SAY THAT.
THEY KNOW THIS FROM THE OBAMA
BIDEN YEARS OF 2010 AND 2014
WHERE THEY LOST SEATS.
IF IT'S A CHOICE BETWEEN BIDEN
OR TRUMP, THAT'S WHAT THE TEAM
WANTS TO HEAR.
THAT'S WHAT THE BIDEN TEAM
WANTS.
EVERYBODY IS DEALING WITH
INFLATION EVERY DAY.
IT'S A REFERENDUM ON THE
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S WHAT THE MID-TERMS ARE
ABOUT.
>> THEY CAN TRY TO MAKE IT A
CHOICE.
AS A COMMUNICATIONS PERSON, IF I
WAS PLANNING TO HAVE MY BOSS
GIVE A BIG SPEECH ABOUT LOWERING
GAS PRICES AND I WAKE UP AND THE
HEADLINES ARE AAA SAID IT'S
RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES AND YOU
COME OUT AND YOU BUILT SOMETHING
AS A NEW PLAN AND YOU GIVE AN
ENTIRE SPEECH THAT HAS NOTHING
NEW IN IT, THEN YOU HAVE LOST
THE CONFIDENCE OF THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE TURNING TO YOU HOPING
THAT YOU PROVIDE THEM SOME
RELIEF.
THEY KNOW IT'S NOT COMING.
>> Jesse: GREG GUTFELD?
WHY DO YOU LOOK SO --
>> Greg: WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
SAY ABOUT ULTRA MAGA, IT'S A
TROJAN HORSE.
>> Dana: EXACTLY WHAT I'M TRYING
TO SAY.
>> Greg: I WAS HOLDING THAT IN
FOR SO LONG.
THEN YOU HAVE SENATOR SCOTT
RESPONDING.
SENATOR SCOTT, THIS IS LIKE
REALLY HARSH.
IT'S HARSH BY MY STANDARDS.
HE SAID THAT BIDEN IS
INCAPACITATED, INCOHERENT,
UNWELL, UNFIT, CONFUSED,
INCAPABLE.
THOSE ARE ALL THE WORDS THAT
RICK SCOTT USED.
IT'S LIKE SOMEBODY THREW A CAN
OF PAINTS ON BIDEN AND NOBODY IS
HELPING HIM WIPE IT OFF.
BIDEN SAID RICK SCOTT IS NOT
WELL.
NOBODY IS BOTHERING TO DEFEND
HIM BECAUSE ALL OF THOSE THINGS
COULD BE ARGUED PERSUASIVELY.
I'M WITH YOU ABOUT THE MAGA
PHRASE.
IT SHOWS HOW LITTLE GAME THAT
THEY HAVE THAT NO ONE IS PICKING
IT UP AND LAUGHING AT IT.
IT'S NOT LET'S GO BRANDON; WHICH
WAS GENIUS BECAUSE OF THE
SUBTERFUGE AND IT'S NOT VISUAL
LIKE DIRTY HARRY.
IT'S LIKE A LOSER THAT CHOSES A
NAME AND KNOCK PICKS IT UP.
JOE LOOKS GREAT ON THE SUIT.
PUTS ON THE BOMBER JACKET, THE
AVIATION JACKET, HE LOOKS LIKE
THE HEAD OF THE FLIGHT CREW THAT
GOT MISTAKEN AS THE PILOT.
HE SHOULD BE MESSING UP THE KIDS
HAIR AND GIVING THE WINGS TO THE
GIRL.
HE SHOULD NOT BE IN THE COCKPIT.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE REALIZED HE'S
IN THE COCKPIT.
YOU HAVE TO GET HIM OUT.
>> Jesse: THERE'S NO GAME WITH
ULTRA MAGA.
IF YOU ARE MAGA, YOU'RE NOT LIKE
OH, ULTRA MAGA.
HE GOT ME.
JANINE, HOW DO YOU THINK THIS
WILL PLAY?
>> Jeanine: I DON'T THINK IT
WILL PLAY AT ALL.
HE SAID HIS POLICIES HAVE HELPED
MORE THAN THEY HURT?
WHERE IS THE DISINFORMATION
BOARD WHEN YOU NEED IT?
NOTHING HE SAYS IS TRUE.
THE ALL THAT MAGA PLAN.
THE FACT THAT ULTRA IS SUPPOSED
TO TEE IT UP.
YOU REALLY HATE MAGA, YOU REALLY
HATE ULTRA MAGA.
I SPOKE TO SENATORS.
HE SAID NOBODY SIGNED ON TO RICK
SCOTT'S PLAN.
THAT MEANS NOTHING.
IT'S NEVER GOING TO MAKE THE
FLORIDA.
MITCH McCONNELL DOESN'T LIKE IT.
RICK SCOTT, THE JUNIOR SENATOR
FROM FLORIDA, WHO CARES?
JOE BIDEN IS CARING HIS PLANS TO
NOTHING.
WHAT MAKES ME CRAZY ABOUT BIDEN
IS HE SAYS, WE'RE GOING TO PLAN
TO REDUCE THE PRESCRIPTION DRUG
PRICES.
YOU ARE?
DO IT.
YOU HAVE THE HOUSE, YOU HAVE THE
SENATE, YOU HAVE THE OVAL.
WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO DO THIS
STUFF?
ALL HE CAN DO IS SHARPENING THE
RHETORIC TO THE REPUBLICANS AND
EVERYBODY SAYS GAS IS $4 OR $5.
NOTHING HAS CHANGED.
>> Jesse: DID YOU SEE ANYTHING
DIFFERENT IN THE SPEECH TODAY
BESIDES THE SHARP PARTISAN
ATTACK?
>> WE'RE GETTING INTO POLITICAL
SEASON.
HEAVY INTO IT.
I DO THINK THIS ULTRA MAGA
THING -- LOOK, YOUR VIEWS AROUND
THE TABLE ARE RESPECTABLE AND
UNDERSTANDING BUT IT COULD BE
SOMETHING THAT STICKS.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENS TO
OHIO, J.D. VANCE WINS.
MORE THAN 2/3s VOTED AGAINST
J.D. VANCE VOTED AGAINST HIM.
RICK SCOTT IS THE HEAD OF THE
REPUBLICAN SENATE CAMPAIGN
COMMITTEE.
HIS ROLE IS IMPORTANT TO
REPUBLICANS WINNING BACK THE
SENATE THIS GO AROUND.
IF HE HAS A PLAN THAT DIFFERS
FROM MITCH McCONNELL, IF THERE
WERE A DEMOCRAT THAT HAD A
DIFFERENT PLAN THAN BIDEN, WE
WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT IT
NEGATIVELY.
I'D BE CRITICIZING IT.
THIS GUY HAS A DIFFERENT PLAN
THAN MITCH McCONNELL WHO IS I
THINK EFFECTIVE MINORITY LEADER
AND MAJORITY LEADER AS WE'VE
SEEN.
WE NEED TO BE HONEST.
THE PANDEMIC AND THE WAR HAVE
INCREASED FUEL PRICES.
I WOULD HAVE EXPECTED THE
PRESIDENT'S MESSAGE EVEN MORE,
BEEN MORE CREDIBLE TO SAY WE'RE
GOING TO INCREASE ENERGY
PRODUCTION HERE AT HOME.
OIL AND NATURAL GAS HAVE TO BE
UPPED AS WE THINK ABOUT GOING
FORWARD AND GET TO A GREEN
ENERGY PLATFORM IN THE COUNTRY.
UNTIL THEN, WE HAVE TO PRODUCE
MORE FOSSIL FUELS.
LAST, WE HAVE TO RAISE TAXES ON
BILLIONAIRES.
ANYBODY THAT IS NOT FOR THAT --
>> Jesse: AREN'T YOU A
BILLIONAIR
BILLIONAIRE?
>> IF I WERE, I'D BE HAPPY TO.
WE'VE HAD THE MAJORITIES FOR A
WHILE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE HAD THE
MAJORITIES, SENATOR OBAMA HAD IT
AND NOW BIDEN.
THEY HAVE YET TO RAISE THE TAX
THAT ALLOW AS GROUP OF INVESTORS
THAT ARE INVESTING OTHER
PEOPLE'S MONEY TO ENJOY A
DIFFERENT TAX WHEN THEY MAKE
MONEY.
WHEN I MAKE MONEY, I PAY REGULAR
TAXES.
DEMOCRATS RAISE THAT ONE FIRST.
I'M NOT MAD ABOUT THE ULTRA MAGA
THING.
>> Jesse: YOU THINK IT'S GOING
TO STICK?
>> IF IT DOESN'T GO TO SOMETHING
ELSE.
>> Dana: MAGA WILL SAY I'M ULTRA
MAGA.
SO WHAT IS THE LEVEL AFTER
ULTRA?
>> Greg: THEY'RE TRYING TO -